hello people welcome to the Rubin report
I'm Justin Bieber's egg salesman Dave
Rubin I've got max Luger beer and Jack
Moore with me and of course we have to
start with the Bieber this is clearly
the most important news of the day cops
sheriff's showed up to Justin Bieber's
compound I'm calling it a compound
mansion whatever you want to call it
because there was an egg incident
vandalism eggs were thrown there may
have been as much as 20 thousand dollars
worth of damage to Justin Bieber's
neighbor's house anything over 950 950
dollars would be a felony the Bieber
could be in trouble
lil za I didn't know who he was but
apparently he's a rapper friend to
Bieber he got arrested might be coke
might be ecstasy might be xanax okay so
nobody wants to talk about this stuff
it's such nonsense but it was literally
the lead story on cnn.com it was
trending on Twitter of course all that
stuff and all the news organizations
covering it so I feel like that's worthy
of talking about how do we decide what
should even be in the discussion and
what about the news organizations like
come a CNN really a front page like I
mean that was the biggest headline of
the day really I mean they're they're
whoring for cliques a guess I mean
that's the only explanation cuz it's
really like it's absurd that that we are
paying this much attention to like an
egg throwing incident you know it's
awful yeah now the irony isn't lost on
me that of course I'm now talking about
it which just feeds the Beast
do you want to say yes I could see you
in the head tilt everywhere going Dave I
know what you're doing here but really
what like so for a regular news
organization I get you can touch on it
but literally when they're covering this
as the lead story now you know we're
having some issues with NSA have you
heard about that and Obamacare and Iran
says we surrendered you know so there's
some other [ __ ] going down it was also
CNN in the Jeff Zucker world like
they've made a point that they're gonna
step away from kind of classical news in
a lot of ways they're trying to move
more towards entertainment yeah to
position themselves better against MSNBC
and and Fox which are kicking their
asses over and over and over again for
years so I think we're still see I mean
this is the same organization that
dedicated like what non-stop covered for
like four days to the poop cruise
pretty bad but never forgets yeah
hashtag never forget but yeah so I think
it's not totally surprising and but at
the same time everybody is talking about
it like it's it's hard it's a
chicken-egg situation but people do are
interested and it is kind of an
interesting crazy story yeah it's
completely nuts and I'm not diminishing
the ridiculous of and how many freaking
eggs for $20,000 worth of damage I know
they obviously we're free the most
ridiculous element of the stories how
did I do twenty thousand dollars or the
damage with a carton of eggs really
fancy windows you know stuff like that
ridiculous I do like I think you were
right to call be bursting a compound
because he often think of him in Noriega
and the same in the same breath but I
can't imagine what the cops were looking
for like what why do you need 12 like or
whatever to come talk to him what are
you searching like are you taking eggs
out of the refrigerator mr. beebe oh
yeah yeah
like don't tell me a friend's mom pays
for it actually is a great point because
we always think that celebrities get
special treatment as if it's better but
in this case if I had egged my
neighbor's house I'm pretty sure twelve
cops wouldn't have shown up and started
searching my house cuz what is the
evidence there look I mean are they
looking for egg crates they end up
finding cocaine or ecstasy or writerly
he's had altercations before with the
police and he doesn't usually comply
like he doesn't usually talk to the cops
so I think that like they were just
trying you know he probably was I wasn't
it this was probably an instance of that
you know where he was like not wanting
to talk to them all right well I think
we've given this story sort of the
gravitas that it deserves but shouldn't
we expect this kind of stuff from rock
stars like what happened to the days
when rock stars were allowed to trash
rooms and destroy you know hotels and
burn cows in airplanes and all kinds of
fun stuff what happened to that I don't
think they used to live in these gated
communities in Calabasas though like I
think they they would go and like you
know they'd live in cities and like Sid
and Nancy we're staying at the Chelsea
Hotel I'm like you know like they did
trash hotel rooms is up but they also
stopped you know now they live next to
bankers and bankers don't give a [ __ ]
like they have real money and like real
like money that will last beyond the
time when they're cute okay
I think littles oz of the littles Oz of
the world are gonna have a lot of Justin
Bieber's money by the time it's all said
and done the entourage always seems to
not go broke yeah do you guys think
celebs are having more breakdowns now or
it's just that now it's tweeted all the
time like it's ly we're live tweeting
the stuff literally as it's happening
sometimes before it's happening I mean I
mean an incident like this I don't know
if you can if you should necessarily
chalk it up to the fact that he is a
rock star I mean he's still a kid and
you know I grew up in New York City and
I definitely like there were instances
when I would you know bring out some
eggs with friends of mine and throw him
in buses which is a fun thing to do but
I think we do stupid things and you
learn from them he the problem with him
is that he doesn't seem to be learning
from them from the stupid things that
he's doing in the swamp bucket I thought
that was gonna be his like final yeah so
final thought on this Charlie Sheen I
was thinking about Charlie Sheen with
all this Charlie Sheen's doing blow with
hookers and had you know his whole Tiger
was tiger juice tiger tiger hallelujah
[ __ ] wonderful I guess that's the
point that is the win is that we forgot
what it was yeah but but when you think
about it someone like ty what do you
think he thinks of this like he's going
I'm doing it you know what I mean like
if I'm gonna do it I'm gonna really do
it and you're egging someone's house
dude Justin Bieber is sort of like the
real-life version of blank check he's
sort of like when a kid gets way too
much money and is like I'm gonna stay up
all night and drink soda like an egg
houses and and hang out with guys with
coke or ecstasy like he's really mixing
worlds maybe like the lamest version of
superstardom
ever you can't imagine Justin Bieber
look Dennis the Menace which is not cool
like it's he seems like he literally has
his older neighbor being like kid get
off my lawn like it's crazy
exactly alright well from one breaking
scandal to another that sort of is a
scandal and seems to maybe be getting
bigger even though no one knows if the
guy knew about it in the first place
Chris Christie
of course everyone knows what happened
they shut down some lanes in Fort Lee
New Jersey on the way to the George
Washington Bridge it now turns out that
it might have been political retribution
for a mayor of Fort Lee who didn't
endorse him when he was running for
governor he had the State of the State
Union yesterday in New Jersey let's take
a look at the last week has certainly
tested this administration mistakes were
clearly made and as a result we let down
the people we're entrusted to serve I
know our citizens deserve better much
better now I'm the governor and I'm
ultimately responsible for all that
happens on my watch both good and bad
now without a doubt we will cooperate
with all appropriate enquiries to ensure
that this breach of trust does not
happen again but I also want to assure
the people of New Jersey today that what
has occurred does not define us or our
state okay I have no great love for
chris Christie but there is no actual
smoking gun here there were emails that
implicated other people he's now fired
someone and already is doing the process
that he's agreeing with the with the
legal system to go ahead and deal with
this so I have no great love for the guy
but there is nothing pinning this on him
specifically so I don't know how much
more the guy could do at this moment if
it turns out that everything he said in
the press conference was not true then
he'll have to deal with that but the guy
fired somebody there's nothing pinning
him directly to it so how much more do
people want from him I I'm defending him
I know that's the thing is I kind of
want to defend him to one because it
just doesn't seem like that big of a
deal like I realized that there were
consequences to it and like but there
are consequences to everything that are
unforeseen and people driving like you
never know what's gonna happen right
supposedly there was an ambulance and we
got there yeah and like that's obviously
awful yeah but it's also like the sort
of badass to be like oh you know I don't
know I like weirdly find myself being it
like that
kind of an awesome move like I hate to
be that's like I just remember like and
it's funny to me because like liberals
of course and I am count myself among
them yeah think of for years the West
Wing was like our refuge during the Bush
administration like we could like for an
hour a week pretend Jed Bartlet's
president and one of the funny moments
of his reelection campaign is that they
send of the presidential motorcade
through New York to keep the other guy
in to tie up traffic so he keep the
other candidate can't get to an event
and it seems like oh man our liberal
heroes are so smart and funny and now
Chris Christie does it and everybody's
like what a bully and it's like yeah
that's kinda why I like Chris Christie
we lose a bet you know you totally hit
them where I wanted to go with this
thing because don't you feel like
everyone does this that doesn't diminish
what he did and especially if someone
died or that you shouldn't be doing
political retribution but are we to
believe do you not think that the
Clintons have done this this you know if
someone doesn't endorse you then you go
out and try to harm them I'm not saying
that's how it should be that's how it is
you know it's part of the problem and I
do think like the the traffic on that
bridge is already terrible and like all
the points that were raised about like
emergency service vehicles not be
totally get through yeah I mean that's
really bad I don't know like I don't
think there's any way to or any reason
necessarily to sugarcoat it like bad is
bad yeah but if they can't pin it to him
directly if there's no proof and in the
neck because they're gonna keep pushing
this obviously the media likes this
story and you can use all the fat puns
so everyone loves that well like if they
can't really pin it on him then we sorta
have to give him a pass right he fired
the woman that they could pin it on like
how much more can we ask them to do yeah
well what else was he supposed to do you
know well that's my boy that's my quote
not defending him but the guy did we
always ask our leaders to take you know
acknowledge when something's gone wrong
he said this is my fault even though I
didn't know about it I fired somebody we
keep saying that Obama you know the NSA
he doesn't know exactly what was
happening or Obama care you can keep it
I didn't know what was happening you
know it's Saturday I think that's exact
there's a good argument you made that he
because especially what's so frustrating
I think part of why this story is taking
hold is because nobody like liberals
want to take down Chris Christie because
he poses a threat in 2016
yeah and Republicans don't love him and
we can we get out from under Chris
Christie I mean like good there's your
fat like kid there they see it as
opportunity so there's nobody like Glenn
Beck is trashing chris Christie like
there's nobody usually this is the type
of thing where Fox News would close
ranks and talk about how the liberal
media is attacking a Republican leader
who we should you know that ridiculous
they do the same thing right but instead
you have Glenn Beck being like you know
or Rudy Giuliani you know who did defend
Chris Christie actually came out and
sort of just like used the opportunity
to defend Obama - it was like he
probably didn't know what was going on
with Benghazi or gonna you know so you
can't have it both ways
either you know Barack Obama doesn't
know everything that happens in the
country which I'm betting he doesn't
right or chris Christie you know he does
and chris Christie is totally an evil
mastermind yeah yeah I totally agree I
mean so how do who would want to go into
politics when you see a story like this
where do you see this kind of thing
let's just say for a second he's being
honest and did not know nobody is in
charge of he's the guys at the head of
the state he's in charge of literally
thousands of people you don't know what
everybody's doing so who in their right
mind would ever want to run for public
office if everything that below you can
be pinned on you doesn't extreme right
nuts I mean I especially the day when we
contract every right doesn't it seem
nuts yeah do you want to run for office
I don't know yeah it sounds it sounds
like a job that I would know what yeah I
that's a question I mean the who would
want for us because the reason it's
anyone down they'll say oh well you're
cheap a step did this 20 years ago and
it well that's it's that moment that is
just awful in like every movie we're
like the like every bad indie movie
we're like some like good people find
themselves in bad situations we're like
the crazy friend like brings a guy's
head to his butt like look what I did
for you
oh my god we're in trouble now I didn't
want it's like it's like their dog
bringing you a dead bird and you're like
no this is not
presents like stott like and now he's
responsible because it just for a host
of reasons one would not want to run the
fact that he's gotten this far in fact
that anybody gets elected is a miracle
to me yeah but I don't understand the
the appeal of putting yourself at risk
for a thousand people who all want to
show that they're the good soldier
that's gonna like do it for right
without even telling you so a final
thought on this related to 2016 and you
touched on this isn't this just all too
early if the goal here really was to
just hurt the guy you know they could
have sat on this because now there's
these other little scandals coming out
so it's like you know when it rains it
pours kind of thing but isn't all this
too early there's no way we can't
remember anything a week later much less
this is way too early to do damage to
the guy really don't you think yeah yeah
I think so um you know we've got plenty
of time you know plenty of other
scandals are gonna happen between now
and then so yeah I know I mean it's it's
crazy when you think about even the last
election if you looked at it two months
out before Hurricane sandy and stuff the
election was totally different yeah you
know if you looked at 2008 before the
economy tanked and McCain suspended his
campaign like if you looked at that I'm
two months before the election it was
totally different than what happened at
the end none of this matters
it just doesn't just like Benghazi
didn't destroy Hillary this is not going
to destroy Chris Christie like this is
all just gawking and something to fill
our time we all agreed the eggs will
destroy Bieber right oh sorry Bieber
okay let's move on this is I think
absolutely the biggest issue going on
right now and very few people are
talking about it unfortunately net
neutrality which basically means that
the Internet service providers have to
give equal access to everything online
it has been struck down by a court this
this is really quite terrible so let's
look at the definition of just a basic
definition of what net neutrality is so
it's the principle that all sites on the
internet will be equally accessible so
if you have time warner let's say for
Internet they can't slow down sites that
they are not affiliated with so the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals ruled in
Verizon's favor the court said that
because the f
she had previously placed broadband
internet service in a separate
regulatory category from phone service
it lacked legal justification to impose
the open Internet rules okay so that's a
lot of mumbo-jumbo but basically Verizon
wants to be able to control if you have
Verizon as your internet provider they
want to give you access to their stuff
and their partner is faster than other
stuff I think this is huge this is so
horrible and that neutrality is so
important this is I really think this
miss in the NSA are like the two
defining things of our generation why
isn't this a bigger deal no it should be
especially because like you just know
that when this sort of power is put into
the hands of conglomerates like Time
Warner Cable who I'm a subscriber to
only because they're like a monopoly in
my neighborhood yeah like they're
totally gonna exploit it you know to the
best of their ability and I just think
it's awful it's terrible it's it's is
awful but it's it's also shocking to me
that the people who are making these
decisions these judges these like do
they understand what's going like I feel
like it's the same I have the same issue
with that I have whenever Congress gets
involved in anything on the internet
it's like these people are like laughs
at the guy who comes in to give them
because these are nerve because them to
give them like information and I don't
trust them to actually know the
implications of what this means yeah I
don't think these are people who are
using the Internet in the same way that
young people or having young people like
adults now like the next generation of
people are using the Internet and it is
I mean the one silver lining yeah is
that it's been said Comcast
for instance is going to continue hat is
committed to continuing that neutrality
through 2018 which does give us time to
potentially legislate or you know find
other routes to net neutrality
it's just Court decisions like this make
that a lot yeah so isn't this one of
those stories that it goes to what we
started with here the Bieber thing and
the eggs like that's the story that
leads cnn.com the same day the net
neutrality gets struck down because we
it's too hard to explain I think I did a
pretty decent two sentence job of it but
like you'd have to actually understand
some technical things as opposed to eggs
on a window my god
Asians are that like a company like like
Time Warner could charge extra for you
know HD YouTube streams or something
like that or like give slower access to
shopping sites if they decided to launch
their own right right which is terrible
no it's it's all terrible yeah it's
awful and the fact that we don't have a
marketplace right now where you have
options you kind of alluded to that but
like it's not like I can leave Time
Warner tomorrow and go to cable vision
because there I think maybe I have an
AT&T choice which I've heard is really
bad for Internet yeah there's no
alternative and they and they already
like you know are terrible you know in
terms of customer service and and like
I'm gonna use them and I've had nothing
but awful experiences with them yeah and
this will just turn the internet into
cable TV which is the problem is that
you can get a basic subscription they
don't give you email and basic browsing
but then if you want Netflix you have to
pay this much what and nobody wants that
there's nobody but the conglomerates
that want that and this is another
example just it nothing that isn't the
public's interest but yeah there's no
regular human being who's like I
actually prefer my Internet yeah and if
that's the case if there's no human
being who's like this is a better option
why would we do that doesn't that go to
everything we talked about with politics
all the time here is that they're making
all these decisions and the last people
that are involved they're actually the
people nobody wants this I have yet to
hear anyone outside of this judge
basically and and Comcast and Time
Warner the people that are gonna profit
from it say it's okay do you guys think
we're gonna look back on the 20 years
let's say that we've all that the
Internet has really existed since the
let's say the late 90s when was the
Netscape started the whole thing or
whatever was a prodigy do you think
we're gonna look back on it as like the
Golden Age of the internet like we look
back on the Golden Age of TV because now
between this and the NSA so now it's
like we got people watching us and
they're controlling how fast we can get
stuff not that uh that the first 20
years when we didn't know they were
watching and before they could control
the access you think we're gonna look
back and think wow it was it was pretty
good the Wild West
I do I also maybe I'm naive I still hope
that it's just not gonna happen like I
think and maybe that's the wrong message
to sign maybe the message I'm just like
this guy is following like
you know people of America do something
like but I I think that at the end of
the day I just I look at what happened
with like SOPA and nobody cared
and at the last minute everybody
realized how bad it was and Congress
like got in line and did the right thing
yeah
temporarily right and I'm sure that's
probably gonna be flipped to it yeah but
I I just I do think that it there's
still time like I don't think it's over
yet like and maybe that's not if maybe
I'm the guy it's the bottom of the ninth
and we're down 30 runs and I'm like we
can still do it guys but you know right
what do you think we'll look at it back
as the Golden Age don't you see it the
the winds have changed well I'm always I
tend to be optimistic I think like as is
the case with most technologies once the
genie is out of the bottle you know you
can't easily put it back in and so I
think that like if people are really
dissatisfied as I am assuming they will
be you know I think I don't think that
they'll let it happen I think the other
kind of x-factor in all this is yes
there are corporations like Comcast and
Time Warner and Verizon who want to end
that net neutrality but Google doesn't
write Facebook doesn't and those are
also giant companies with huge I mean
Google specifically is also rolling out
broadband in a lot of places yeah and
like it with it I mean that's gonna
change here in Los Angeles like Google
broadband is gonna be a thing in a few
years and that's you could be there like
maybe the answer to this is Google ends
up being like alright [ __ ] you guys will
be the internet right so there's your
solution people we need an even bigger
giant corporations who save us Google
Fiber I think is just in Kansas and
maybe Texas right now has to come it's a
mess all right let's talk about gay
stuff because it was a pretty good week
already for the gays and it's only
Wednesday yesterday a federal judge
ruled that Oklahoma's gay marriage ban
was unconstitutional let's take a look
at a quote equal protection is at the
very heart of our legal system and
central to our consent to be governed it
is not a scarce commodity to be meted
out but grudgingly or in short portions
therefore the majority view in Oklahoma
must give way to individual
constitutional rights now he immediately
stayed
decision so gays can't get married
immediately in Oklahoma and already you
know a couple weeks ago this happened in
Utah they had it temporarily now it
looks like it's gonna go to the Supreme
Court
so all right I'm gonna pretty much think
we all agree that this is basically good
right gays equality are we okay with the
quality super okay all right so we're
agreed on the Equality thing so I'm
gonna switch gears a little bit do is
there a risk in this all happening by
judges are we just strengthening the
resolve of the other side is the tea
party are those people just gonna be
more pissed because they're gonna say
it's not the will of the people
it's the activist judges that are giving
the gays all this power no I mean I
don't think if you were a tea party guy
and you were against these judges making
decisions that you wouldn't this
wouldn't strengthen your I mean yeah I
guess potentially potentially I just
can't wait until we get to a point where
we don't have to celebrate common sense
you know trust me I did not want to do I
can't wait till we don't have to do
these stories I don't think that will be
and I mean I think people will complain
because people complain and so if you're
losing you're gonna be like this is not
the way it should be done let's do it
away where we win exactly because we've
seen we've seen cases where the people
have voted in favor of gay marriage and
then people are upset for other you know
there's always bitter losers yeah but I
think I've won equality in this country
usually goes one way it doesn't it's
very rare that rights are taken away
from people continuously or for a long
time when they are it's usually quickly
reversed and outright you know and we're
seeing that now with it with this issue
you know when Utah has judges being like
you like they're gay married people in
Utah like there's gonna be gay marriage
in Utah right it may not happen again
tomorrow but that's gonna happen now and
it doesn't go it's not gonna go back
right so the people in Utah for example
that are fighting it I mean they don't
they know that they're fighting a losing
cause here because it's exactly what
happened in California there was the
temporary okay and now a couple thousand
people and in Utah remarried and they
know that they're not gonna get it back
so is it just that they just
can't give up there what they view as
the the righteous fight or whatever you
think it's just they can't give up that
religious fervor that religious yeah
craziness
it is craziness um yeah I don't know I
mean I just I hope that they get it back
you know I think they can't give up the
fight because it is this thing they can
go to church and feel like they're being
holy or something I don't I don't know I
was raised Catholic and one of the like
the fact that I've for the first time
ever I'm like hey this Pope's not bad
like that's like even not to move it in
a good direction so I I do think I think
in terms of judges to like equality in
this country's always dealt like doled
out by activist judges like you know
Brown versus the Board of Overseers I've
stood for a long time that doesn't mean
people won't try to overturn them as we
see with roe v-- wade constantly but you
know it's that's that's how this works
that's their job to is to be like hey
you guys aren't protecting everybody
like we'll protect me right that also
the irony of the people that they say
they're so for the constitution but we
have separation of powers and if they
believe in the Constitution well then
they should believe that if a judge says
this is unconstitutional even if they
don't like it they should abide by it
but somehow they don't always why can't
they also be on the side of the people
when it comes to net neutrality
makes you wonder yeah makes you wonder
you know so governor mary Fallon who's
the governor of Oklahoma she said that
the people of Oklahoma have spoken on
the issue noting that 75% of the voters
supported traditional definition of
marriage
I bet 60 years ago they supported to
white people and to black people getting
me support the two black people getting
married but as long as they weren't
marrying white people it was better yeah
it's you this is an issue where I don't
trust the will of the people like the
fact is there's a right there is a wrong
and it is the government's job to make
sure that all people are treated equally
and so if you have bigoted people in an
area who are gonna vote for something
and bigot is maybe a strong word there
are people with different you know blah
blah but it is a bigoted stances right
at this point
at this point well because that's the
other thing and this will be the final
thought on this that
for these people that are against it it
every time there is gay marriage
somewhere it does none of the things
they say are proven true it doesn't
cause straight people to get divorced or
ruin families it actually strengthens
families they've even done research that
straight marriage is even strengthened
in bizarre ways because you have
healthier families and people yeah yeah
I just want to say that I think it's
really great we got through this segment
without making Rodgers and Hammerstein's
joke like I think that is real real big
I did every Oklahoma joke on Twitter
already and I thought I wouldn't belabor
it were you guys all right let's move on
so this was big and this happened this
week also President Obama said that he
won't wait for Congress to push his
legislative agenda through this sort of
goes to what we were just talking about
because we do have separation of powers
and Congress is supposed to make laws
the president's supposed to execute them
but that's really not what he's saying
he's going to do here he's gonna use
executive orders as much as possible
here's exactly what he said we are not
just going to be waiting for legislation
in order to make sure that we're
providing Americans the kind of help
that they need
I've got a pen and I've got a phone and
if I can use that pen to sign executive
orders and take executive actions and
I've got a phone that allows me to
convene Americans from every walk of
life okay that seems slightly
problematic to me again separation of
powers he's supposed to enact the law is
not write them but he does have some
leeway with this kind of stuff and I'm
not defending Congress they don't do
anything right their approval rates at
7%
they hate the guy they don't want to do
anything with them but isn't there a
little danger in a president that saying
I'm not gonna wait for the rest of the
system to work and I'm just gonna go
ahead and do it I was gonna maverick II
sounds very emperor palpatine from Star
Wars so why I like I yes idealistically
I totally agree
yes it's course but that's wrong because
that's like that is the liberal idea
like our ideal is you you kind of want
things to work the way they're supposed
to work and I think that's why we always
lose is because the other side doesn't
really care yeah if things worked that
way like I think a big complaint about
President Obama's first term is that he
tried there
hard to do things the right way and they
said no every time exactly and I think
when you look at how Bush and Cheney ran
things it was with kind of an iron fist
and I didn't like those decisions so I
really I really hated the means that
they were gotten but if that if those
are now the rules of the game Democrats
can't get into the White House lose at
every legislative opportunity for eight
years hand it back to the other side and
be like okay you guys destroy the
country and then world like do our best
to fix it the right what like you kind
of have to otherwise the pendulum has to
swing the other way or nothing we're
just gonna keep going down a darker
smaller governments less protection path
right but isn't there a risk in the
pendulum swinging the other way and then
you know let's say a Republican gets in
that you don't agree with his agenda and
then he says well screw you Congress
because Obama set the president I'm
gonna do everything by executive order
so how do we how do we negotiate how
this should all work because you can't
like it if it's your guy and they're not
like if it's the other guy right that's
the principle thing you were talking
about so what I'm talking about is that
I I think Obama hasn't set the precedent
I think this president had been set by
the previous administration and actually
Obama though you has used a lot of
executive orders did not has not used
them in quite as sweeping ways as Bush
has and I think this goes to a bigger
issue with the Democratic Party being so
bad at being Congress at being in
Congress even when they had the majority
and even as a minority there they're
just terrible at uniting behind a thing
like they don't they all because it's
all like oh no the idealistic thing that
nobody wants to compromise in with each
other in a Democrat compromise with the
Republicans see that yeah but we got a
budget this week exactly but it's it's
Democrats are really bad at coming
together and making things happen
Republicans are really good at it and so
whatever way Democrats can move their
agenda for it seems like it's going to
be good because the agenda is going to
be coming back the other way next time
around so he's part of this problem
besides this sort of the specific things
that you're talking about that we sort
of forget what is supposed to govern us
like I've now said the separation powers
ten times but like that we don't really
spend any time really
realizing that we have a branch that
decides what's legal a branch is
supposed to pass the laws and a branch
that's supposed to execute the laws and
because so it really comes to me this
has comes down to education like if
people really understood how the system
is supposed to work
maybe we wouldn't have to deal with a
lot of the nonsense
that Jack's talking about right yes it's
just an education thing no it's a great
point and I think that people you know I
think you know the Affordable Care Act
has been like a really amazing you know
offering of Obama's campaign but I think
in general a lot of people wish that he
would have been able to accomplish more
and so I think six years in to say
something like this I think I don't know
I think it's a it's a positive I don't
know if it's a positive thing
necessarily but I think that people kind
of want to hear that from him right and
also he doesn't have to run for
reelection to this point maybe he's just
putting the the pedal to metal and being
like screw you guys I'm gonna do
whatever the hell I can get away with
what I think you I think you're right
there and I think that's actually the
problem with with the whole situation is
if more congressmen didn't worry about
reelection if there were term limits
that ooh you know could make it that you
know we had a lot of congressmen who
were who were doing it for two terms and
then getting out or three terms and
getting out then I think you could see
more movement in a good way but
everybody so worried about protecting
their seats that just nothing is going
to get done it's a balance between
idealism and practicality and the fact
is like I want the idealistic version to
work but then we have to fix the system
and like give and sent it like the
incentives are aligned with our best
interests yeah all right let's move on
we got one more about judges and the
system a federal judge denied
preliminary approval of a 765 million
dollar settlement on NFL concussion
claims we've all seen the videos we're
just getting more and more of this guy's
can't remember things Brett Favre etc
etc let's look at some of the details a
younger retiree with Lou Gehrig's
disease would get 5 million under the
deal those with serious dementia cases
would get 3 million an 8 year old with
early dementia would get 25,000 that
seems like nothing retirees without
symptoms would get baseline screening
and follow-up care if needed the
proposed settlement by the way which was
negotiated over 7 several months is
designed to last at least 65 years so
again these videos are out I'd to the
playoffs right now I'm watching this it
seems like the
hits are getting worse and worse but
maybe it's just because we're getting
sensitized to it now because everyone's
talking about it
is this crazy that even a 765 million
dollar deal was not enough in this
judges eyes to do this I mean I think
that the problems are real you know a
lot of these players are playing through
injuries which is part of the problem
you know maybe they get diagnoses from
doctors you know of concussions and
whatnot and they and they continue to
play but I'm really concerned I mean I
think it is a growing problem like you
alluded to I think that the injuries are
getting worse a friend a really good
friend of mine just did a documentary
about traumatic brain injury and it's an
exploration of how the extreme sports
you know like it's getting so
increasingly competitive and like people
are just pushing really their human
bodies to the limits and it's just
becoming more and more dangerous you
know there was a two weeks ago there was
like a UFC fight and I don't follow UFC
at all but one of the like I guess you
know best fighters in the world or
something completely shattered his uh
you know all of the bones basically in
his lower leg and I just thought that
it's like I mean how is this
entertainment you know like seeing
people get so badly hurt right so we'll
get we'll get to that part cuz I think
that is a key part but what do you think
of the settlement in general the judge's
decision on the settlement does that to
show you how bad this really it's the
judge's decision is awesome it's
hilarious
haha [ __ ] the NFL like this is like I
love football I'd watch it every week
I'm part of the problem but at the same
time is a nine billion dollar industry
the seven or 65 million dollars is not
like for 65 years the number of athletes
that the reason the judge just decided
this was because that the amount settled
on would not actually cover the things
that they're covering right that they
want to cover because there are so many
injuries it's so prevalent there's so
many brain injuries that's so prevalent
that it's just it's not going to be
enough money practically did you know
that Lou Gehrig's disease was even
connected to this
I actually did not realize that and
that's I think what's so I mean when you
[ __ ] with people's brains a lot like
that's bad things happen who knew yeah
and it's not and the problem is I mean
NFL is trying to make the game safer you
know targeting hits hits it to the head
learning show you know that there was
Percy Harvin gut
crushed in that Saints game and so he
wasn't you know when that happens you
have to go out immediately and get a
concussion screening but then he came
back after ten minutes you're supposed
to be fifteen you know it's like it's
fifteen minutes you didn't have a
concussion you maybe want to sit for a
minute and that's it's you know and yes
they're getting better when you are
diagnosed with the concussion you have
to sit out a game you know like so it's
it thing then I felt doing what they can
to improve but I think the big thing is
the NFL will have to change in a
fundamental way and I think we're
starting to see that but I think it will
continue I think the game we watch in
ten years or ten years maybe it gave me
much in twenty years if we're what like
if it's still a thing will look very
different yeah and I think this
settlement the thing that bothers me
about this um is everybody kind of
agrees that it's not enough and the
lawyers who were on the players side
it's like yeah but if we go to court
it's really hard to put like even though
we all know this is what's causing it's
really hard to prove that this is why
all these guys have it yeah so you hit
on a bunch of stuff that I want to get
on there so first up do you think that
some of this maybe will be corrected by
science because with stem-cell research
and all that kind of stuff there is a
chance that for all of the the horrible
things that are happening to these guys
with dementia and all that that maybe
science will catch up and sort of
mitigate some of the health issues yeah
I mean I think that science is working
in parallel to find you know solutions
for you know these horrible diseases I
mean I Alzheimer's is set right now to
be the world's next great epidemic I
mean the numbers of people affected are
gonna triple by 2050 but I think that
like traumatic brain injury is injury
you know and it's true that like you
know they have pointed TBI traumatic
brain injury to an increased incidence
of things like Lou Gehrig's disease
which is like a terrible disease and so
I just think that it's I think it's
messed up I mean I don't watch any
sports so I'm like an objective party I
think I think it's it's just horrible to
see you're more of a brain guy than a
sports guy yeah Pro brain what would it
take then for a sports guy like yourself
what would it take for you to actually
stop watching because these discussions
ESPN has even been doing a little bit
about this is there some magic number
that actually would turn people away
like when if Brett Favre in two years
from now you know
knock on wood but if he really had you
know someone actually I think cuz jr.
say oh I thought was gonna be the big
chain cuz like he was not you know he's
a young guy he was something that we all
remember yeah from not that long ago as
an all-pro for years and he tragically
killed himself because he was dealing
with these things like that it's and yet
no nobody cared I think two things one
ESPN is doing a better job it is also in
a very strange position where they are
the huge financial partner with the NFL
the top ten plays and five of them are
crushing hits and then they do a story
and then they pull out of stories to you
know they pulled out of the frontline
documentary about about this after you
know endorse FB we don't know for sure
but it seems and and the word was
because of pressure from the NFL not to
do it because there which compromises
them as a journalistic enterprise and
they're the journalists to get the prize
in sports so that's a problem is that
the people that are supposed to be
watching this or at least one of the
major players supposed to be watching
this is in bed with the person they're
watching which is a natural issue I
think the the turning point the thing
that will change and I think it's not
impossible is that somebody dies on the
field that would be the like which is
sad that you have to say like somebody's
got to die on the field but like that's
gonna be the thing that like if that
happens and it is certainly within the
realm of possibility which already is
like terrifying I think that will be the
thing that that would change would get
people to really like the general public
do you think part of this has to do with
that the amount of money the players
make even though NFL contracts are not
guaranteed but there'll be most of them
are making millions and millions of
dollars that partly I think people maybe
view this as well it's the risk you take
to make men so there's a a weird lack of
sympathy just because of the salary
they're bringing in does that jive with
you you think that makes sense I think
that that is what leads some of them to
push through their injuries you know and
play when they shouldn't be playing yeah
I mean money there's no incentive quite
like money right yeah it's tough because
I actually think the NFL I think that's
actually the biggest problem or I think
maybe the biggest problem is that the
NFL potential career earnings
average NFL player are much lower than
the other sports because one they're 55
players on our team is opposed to 25 in
baseball or 12 on that in basketball two
contracts aren't guaranteed so an injury
means you stop getting paid potentially
and certainly don't get another contract
necessarily and we focus on people like
Adrian Peterson and and you know Tom
Brady and they're making tons and
millions dodge but the potential earning
for a guy who's on the offensive line
who's a backup who's gonna make five
hundred thousand dollars a year for five
years but then never make that money
ever again and ask doesn't have maybe
skills that are applicable to the fair
world and gets hit with traumatic brain
injury on top of that can't afford the
medical bills a pension plan isn't quite
like you start to you know you start to
see that these aren't necessarily super
rich guys some super rich guys are
dealing with this right but they're also
people that ten years out like they need
like yeah maybe they live in a nice
house but like they need to work in a
car dealership right to be always me for
guys that are making hundred thousand
dollars but a lot of them haven't dealt
with that kind of I venture to say
ninety nine percent of them haven't
dealt with that kind of money beforehand
they get financial advisors involved
that screw up all kinds of things and
all these guys end up broke I mean
there's a zillion stories out of that
yeah it's such a quick turnaround to I
mean you you you look at it and you one
they're paying tons of money agents -
they're paying tons of money to their
entourage because they're young and
stupid and by the time they get smart a
lot of them are out of the league and
it's too late and you that's you see
constantly you know ESPN this is like
they're a good journalistic source in
some ways did that great documentary
called broke about how these got how it
happens and it just it's a mixed mixture
of being dumb a mixture of their targets
and they're not necessarily like yeah
there are really smart football players
but stereotypes exist for reason like
these guys aren't brain surgeons and
their targets for some smart people who
want to take advantage of them yeah when
you throw in the fact that now they're
50 like the average age the lifespan of
an NFL player is like the average age is
like 65 or something it's like
ridiculously low or maybe even younger
than that I've even seen numbers in the
high 50s but the fact that we all this
is the gladiators like we're watching
people kill themselves for our
entertainment and that is a problem and
it
getting safer yeah and that they're
trying to make it safer so you feel a
little better about it but then it hit
like the one Percy Harvin took last
weekend makes you remember like oh yeah
this is still really bad oh yeah he
watches it because it's safe right
right and you know it really reminds me
of hockey which isn't doing particularly
well in America and if they took the
fighting out of that literally nobody
would watch so it's a layered problem
anywho that is our time for today I hope
we didn't give you brain damage during
this I hope maybe you learned a little
song we were all over this we got Bieber
and eggs
we got the judicial system we got some
sports in there follow these guys max
Luger beer jack more there Twitterers
are right down below and we will do this
again next week thanks